royang welcome back to the show
congratulations a big uh victory for you
with the black pieces take us through
the game
um well i think i i like i had like a
good position throughout the game um i
don't really think i messed up that much
anywhere were you surprised by uh her
approach with queen takes d4
early in the year
i was i was expecting another line but
yeah you prepared this move knight to d7
against the roxul with bishop
let's keep going yes
and uh yeah after e5 i was like
originally gonna play e6 and stuff but
like i ain't like like white have some
e5 ideas so
um yeah that might be kind of josh later
on and she was playing fast at this
point she was blessing out her moves
were he concerned by her pace at all
kind of like she it was she like she
usually doesn't go this line so she
probably has prep for something
but then you took away all the squares
that she wanted to place her pieces on
yeah i think she should have taken the
queen here
yes
yeah
queen takes d5 then
i probably castled i guess
and like bishop e6
and the game goes on it's a very complex
middle game after that anything can
happen but she took with the pawn and
you seemed relieved about this uh
uh situation because now at least you
can get your pawns yeah yeah it's like
it's like kind of like a knight of
structure i guess
and white doesn't have like any play at
all on the queen side or i mean she
might but like it's good it's like very
hard to create anything
mm-hmm and uh
when were you let's say certain that you
finally took over taking advantage of
knight takes d6 uh yeah not a
possibility because of queen to c5 yeah
like around here like e4
um you are feeling good right yeah i
think rook d4 was just i think bad
yeah
but like but there was like it wasn't
like it was kind of hard to like try to
like make decisions around here because
like i had like some uh e3 ideas
and e3 were like yeah
basically
yeah and she played it to d4 which
allowed you
to go queen to c5 set up this nice pin
now you didn't even want to put the pawn
on it yeah you wanted to keep the
position open and because like i i i
seen this tactic and she couldn't go
like rick g one because the rook on d4
it's just hanging very nice very nice
spot
take the take and then quickly
well yeah it all looks like a very
dominant victory for you i have to say
and
uh congratulations an important victory
for you you're finishing up uh with who
i think i have talia
talia okay
so talia is very close to the leadership
position you might be trying to play
spoilers in that regard good luck
tomorrow uh rue yang and we'll see you
tomorrow thank you